Wir wollen blicken auf den europäischen Top-Fußball, auf die Premier League mit Uli Hebel, auf die Serie A mit Christian Bernhard und auf La Liga mit Alex Truica. Und genau jetzt geht's los. Schneidet euch an.
Und nun im Programm, der Rasenfunk. Der Blick auf andere Ligen.
Wenn ich nur lang genug warte mit diesem Intro, dann wird es irgendwann richtig schön Retro. Also freuen wir uns schon mal in 10 Jahren drauf. Guten Morgen liebe Herren hier in der Runde. Nachdem wir schon geklärt haben, warum ich ein Boomer bin, freue ich mich, dass wir jetzt über die wirklich wichtigen Dinge reden. Guten Morgen.
Ja, du kannst es leider nicht, oder leider, ich weiß, es ist halt wie es ist, aber du kannst es nicht jeweils einzeln betrachten, weil sie haben sich selbst in dieses Problem manövriert. Das ist so der Erfolgsinparativ durch diese vielen Investments, die sie gemacht haben. Und man kann jetzt noch nicht mal sagen, das ist ja ein weiteres Problem. Ich meine, die hätten die Kohle, um einfach rein zu puttern. Aber dadurch, dass wir gelernt haben, dass die Nachhaltigkeitsregeln in der Premier League genauso hart durchgezogen werden, wie sie aufgesetzt sind, geht das ja nicht ohne weiteres. Das heißt, sie müssen irgendwann anfangen, sich selbst zu finanzieren. Es gibt halt von diesen schlechten Deals, da gibt es auch welche, die kannst du wieder veräußern irgendwann. Also bei Enzo Fernandes als Beispiel, der performt gut genug, dass man für den zumindest eine gewisse Ablösesumme nehmen kann.
Der will ja in der Drittwohnung, hat er gesagt, ne?
Genau, wenn man jetzt das Versus der bezahlten Ablösesumme sieht, dann ist das kein Gewinn mehr, weil ich würde tippen, sie kriegen das nicht hin, dass sie dafür nochmal extra, also die haben sie ja über, über, über bezahlt. Das ist ja auch so ein Blue-Code-Problem gewesen, dass sie damals gesagt haben, als der bei der WM performt hatte in Qatar, das ist der Spieler und man hat den intern so für die Hälfte ungefähr geschätzt. Und dann hat Beda Degbali gesagt, ja, aber können wir den kriegen? Ja, wenn wir halt überbezahlen, weil der hat schon woanders zugesagt. Ja, dann machen. Deshalb werden sie den vermutlich nie wieder persönlich bekommen, aber du kriegst für solche Spieler natürlich nur Ablösesumme. Das wird nicht das Problem sein. Nur, die bringt dich halt so gesehen gar nicht weiter, weil die ja erstmal nur ein Loch stopft, diese Ablösesumme, und du kannst ja nicht weiter ausgeben dann für ihn sozusagen. Und auf diese Verträge, die du zumindest noch vorhäußern kannst, kommen halt auch wahnsinnig miese Deals, die du nie wieder losbekommst. Also mich hat es zum Beispiel sehr gewundert, dass sie Armando Boya losbekommen haben. Kani Chokuemeca ist wahrscheinlich so das beste Beispiel. Das war noch die erste, da haben sie ja ein bisschen gelernt zumindest, das war noch die erste Clear-Lake-Capital-Idee, dass man einfach Spielern höhere Grundgehälter zahlt, damit sie zu ihnen kommen. In Chokuemeca-Fall ging es ja darum, auch englandweit ein Statement zu setzen, wenn wir die besten Jugendspieler wollen, bekommen wir sie. Später haben sie dann gelernt, sie müssen sehr viel stärker leistungsorientiert aufsetzen, diese Verträge. Also nur dann, wenn der Spieler das, das, das, das und das macht, dann kommt die Höhe des Grundgehalts zusammen. Bei Joko Emeka ist einfach nur ein völlig wirrer Betrag, eine Fantasie, den er halt natürlich nie hat reinspielen können und entsprechend wird es große Schwierigkeiten geben, solange der Vertrag läuft, dass den jemand eins zu eins übernimmt, es sei denn der Spieler ist natürlich bereit, davon etwas loszulassen. Und das sind die Probleme, die haben sie nicht bedacht, weil sie gedacht haben, das macht ja nichts. Wenn wir die 50 talentiertesten Spieler zwischen 19 und 23 aneinander rein, werden schon 25 davon durchgehen. Dann werden wir Champions League-Sieger und alles wird gut sein. Mit der Ausschussware– also das ist immer böd, über Menschen so zu reden– aber mit der Ausschussware aus ihrer Sicht, und sie reden ja gar nicht anders intern, haben sie halt nie auch nur ansatzweise zwei Sekunden geplant. Und im Übrigen auch Rosengior. Es gab intern überhaupt gar keine Idee, was denn passieren würde, wenn das nicht funktioniert. Genau. Die stehen jetzt da und haben keine Ahnung, was sie tun sollen. Schon wieder. Und ich war bei zwei, drei Prozessen, habe ich das glücklicherweise über eine Quelle erfahren, dass das genauso ist und war. Und es ist genauso wieder gerade. Die haben überhaupt 0,0 damit gerechnet. Und deshalb sind die jetzt davon total überrascht, dass das hat passieren können.
Jetzt rufen sie halt bei Fabregas an.
Ja, die werden den jetzt…
Ja, aber alle rufen bei Fabregas an.
Entschuldigung.
Genau. Dann sind sie nicht allein.
Dessen Telefon steht schon seit anderthalb Jahren hier.
Die werden den jetzt überzeugen mit einem 9-Jahres-Vertrag und noch höherem Grundgehalt. Wie sonst?
Weiß nicht, ob der sich mit sowas überzeugen lässt.
Da bin ich mir auch nicht so sicher nach dem, was ich so gehört habe. Also ich bin total gespannt. Und eben wie gesagt, es gibt quasi eine Investorensicht auf dieses ganze Chelsea. Zwischenzeitlich debakeln muss man, glaube ich, schon sagen. Die ist echt… Also das wird, glaube ich, auch formen, wie jetzt so der Zukunft, in Zukunft das Investment im Fußball aussieht. Also wir haben… Ich habe da ein Tribüngespräch zugemacht, weil CWC, die ja bei der DFL einsteigen wollten, bei denen läuft so gut bei ihren Sportgeschäften, dass sie die jetzt in ein eigenes Unternehmen ausgelagert haben und Geld und Kredite aufgenommen haben, weil sie damit zu viel Verlust gemacht haben. Es ist in Deutschland hier kaum berichtet worden. Und ich habe eben dann mit zwei Experten darüber gesprochen, was das heißt. Und ganz, ganz verkürzt gesagt ist es so, dass die Preise jetzt einfach viel zu hoch sind, dass diejenigen, die reingegangen sind in den letzten zwei bis fünf Jahren, mutmaßlich zu viel bezahlt haben. Und vor allem, dass es extrem schwierig ist, aus dem laufenden Geschäftsbetrieb Geld rauszuziehen als Investor. Denn die Vereine sind alle so auf Kante genäht, dass die letztlich alle auf einer schwarzen Null operieren. Das ergibt auch Sinn eigentlich aus der Logik der Vereine heraus, heißt aber für Investoren, dass sie nur dann Geld verdienen, wenn sie den Verein verkaufen wieder, also für einen Exit vorbereiten. Und das machen jetzt eben einige schon. Ich meine, bei Böli und Clear Lake wird ja auch darüber berichtet, die haben so eine professionelle Arbeitssituation gerade. Aber es könnte auch sein, dass der eine den anderen rauskauft oder umgedreht. Also Böli, dem nervt das Stadion-Thema unheimlich, nach dem, was man gerade so hört. Das ist aber die einzige Art und Weise, wie du aktuell so richtig Geld verdienen kannst mit diesen Investments. Die Einzigen, die ein bisschen Kohle verdienen, sind CWC in La Liga. Aber da sind es 150 Millionen Euro pro Jahr. Das ist nicht nennenswert für die. Es muss in Milliardenbeträgen sein, sonst funktioniert es nicht. Und das ist gerade ein Problem, in dem ganz viele Multi-Club-Ownership-Strukturen gerade drin sind. Und Chelsea ist da das allerbeste Beispiel, weil die es auch am aggressivsten gemacht haben. Weil sie auch dachten, sie sind schlauer als der Markt. Und jetzt stellt es sich raus, vielleicht doch nicht.
Sie denken es intern immer noch, kann ich dir sagen.
Ja gut, du ey, als ich mich wieder mit diesen ganzen Venture-Capital-Fonds und so weiter beschäftigt habe, die glauben, alle sie hätten eine Mozzarella erfunden. Es ist nicht aus, und ich habe da auch wieder viele Podcasts zur Vorbereitung gehört, nur unsympathische Arschlöcher. Sorry, ich muss es jetzt einfach mal so sagen. Aber Leute, die einfach zu viel Geld haben, die sind nicht mehr in der Lage, anders über die Welt zu denken, als eben mit Investment-Opportunities und zweistelligen Renditen. Und dass da überall Menschen arbeiten und dass es vielleicht auch gut wäre, wenn es auch anderen Menschen gut ginge, nicht nur der eigenen Firma. Das ist so weit weg von allem.
Ja, und einfach auch die Borniertheit zu denken, dass so gewachsene Vereine, die in der Community verankert sind und so weiter, dass du einfach, du lässt zwar den Badge gleich, aber du denkst einfach, du kannst innerhalb von einem Jahr einfach alles ändern, weil du bist viel cleverer, als dies je waren, obwohl die ein halbes Jahr zuvor die Champions League gewonnen haben. Also das ist schon auch, das finde ich, eine besondere Boniertheit irgendwie. Aber wahrscheinlich kommt das mit dem Erfolg, den sie halt ein Leben lang gehabt haben und vermutlich der Verblendung damit. Ich weiß es nicht.
Das ist die…
Ganz kurz, wir haben jetzt keinen Frankreich-Experten hier, aber bei Straßburg funktioniert es sportlich tatsächlich ganz gut, was sie da machen. Ich bin da komplett weit weg, aber sie sind jetzt im Europa League-Finale, im… Für Frankreich Pokal, Halbfinale, Halbfinale, sorry, und im Finale des Frankreich Pokals. Und ich glaube, auf Europa League Champions League Kurs auch wieder. Also sportlich gesehen, bei Straßburg funktioniert es ganz gut.
Aber…
Leider. Ich habe immer auf Klamotten zu.
Ja, aber was verdienen sie damit? Nix. Sie gewinnen ein bisschen, selbst wenn sie die Champions League gewinnen, kriegen sie ein bisschen Kohle, ist nicht viel. Aber selbst wenn sie die Champions League gewinnen, wäre es ja nicht so, dass von, keine Ahnung, sagen wir, 100 Millionen Euro, die sie über die Champions League reinnehmen, 50 wieder rausfließen an den Investor. Sondern es gehen erst mal ganz viele in Prämien, es gehen welche in Transfers und so weiter und so fort. All die Gewinne, die realisiert werden, stehen in Bilanzen, aber die kommen nicht raus als Cashflow oder zumindest nicht in nennenswerter Absicht. Und das ist das Problem, das die Investoren haben.
Ich habe das schon sportlich betrachtet.
Ja, genau. Aber das ist denen ja wurscht.
Die haben schon vermandelt, ne?
Genau. Aber das ist eben das, was die Motoclub-Ownership-Strukturen feststellen, dass sportlicher Erfolg nicht bedeutet, wir verdienen damit Geld. Es gibt eine emotionale Rendite. So haben wir das in der Sendung auch rausgearbeitet. Ich werde es nochmal verlinken, liebe Hörneteure. Hört es euch gerne nochmal an. Es gibt eine emotionale Rendite. Aber Cash gibt es eigentlich nicht, weil das nicht rausfällt. Sogar die Manchester City Group, die haben über die gesamte Zeit hinweg gerechnet, über eine Milliarde US-Dollar-Verlust gemacht. Obwohl ja Manchester City all die Erfolge hatte. Die haben ja irgendwann chinesische Investoren reingeholt. Jetzt haben sie zuletzt Kredite aufgenommen. Die zahlen pro Jahr, ich glaube, wenn ich die Zahl richtig habe, 70 Millionen US-Dollar, nur an Zinsen für ihre Kredite, die sie aufgenommen haben, um das aktuelle Investment weiterlaufen zu lassen. Das heißt, sogar dieses Ding hat nicht funktioniert.
Zumindest haben die aber zwischenzeitlich diese emotionale Rendite auch monetarisieren können. Dass zumindest das Geschäftsergebnis allgemein poliert werden konnte oder kann. Zumindest ein Namen da sind. Minimum mal das, weil das ist bei Chelsea in die gegenläufige Richtung unterwegs. Dadurch, dass die, die halt ortsansässig sind, gar keinen Bock mehr drauf haben.
Ja, genau. Und das kommt noch mit dazu. Das stellen sie dann fest, auch im Moment finden uns ja alle gar nicht toll. Also ich verlinke die Sendung, könnt ihr sehr gerne anhören. Es gibt auch gerade eine Sportsau-Reportage dazu oder eine Doku. Die habe ich noch nicht gesehen, nachdem was ich gehört habe. Hört erstmal die Rasenfunk-Sendung, würde ich jetzt sagen. Weil ich glaube, da geht es ein bisschen tiefer rein. In den Dokus wird erstmal erklärt, was ist ein Multiclub-Ownership. Und ich glaube, da müssen wir jetzt beim Rasenfunk nicht anfangen, das nochmal zu erklären. Aber Chelsea, wirklich hochinteressant aus allen Dingen. Ich, ja, hat die Financial Times da neulich einen interessanten Artikel zu gehabt. Schicke ich euch später mal, also das geht nicht.
Rosengiorg könnte einem fast leidtun, wenn es nicht die 27 Millionen gäbe, weil irgendwie ist das schon ein blöder Knick, du gehst, weil die das so von dir wollen, von einem Verein zum anderen. Also er wollte das sicherlich schon auch so, aber du verlässt ein Projekt, das für dich einigermaßen funktioniert, was dir eine gute Zukunft gegeben hätte, um zu Chelsea zu gehen. Mit dem Wissen oder wahrscheinlich auch dem Auftrag, du hast dir ein paar Jahre Zeit und 107 Tage später bist du um 27 Millionen reicher, ob es dann 100 oder 1 Euro sind. Schau es dir jetzt erstmal zu.
Also ehrlich gesagt, mir tut er gar nicht leid, denn ich bin ganz, ganz sicher, dass neben dem Geld und so weiter, dass Roseno, der wird irgendwo einen Job bekommen. Weil jeder, der ein bisschen anders auf Fußball blickt und nicht in Chelsea drinne, der sieht ja die positiven Aspekte, die du angesprochen hast. Das heißt, den sehen wir dann. Ja gut, in der Bundesliga wahrscheinlich nicht, aber irgendwo.
Bei Tottenham in der 2. Liga.
Nee, die hohen, Eden Tersic habe ich jetzt gelesen.
Oh wei, oh wei.
Schon wieder.
Und Thiel oder was? Thiel und Tersic reunited?
Thiel und Tersic, ja. Aber das ist ja sowieso nochmal was komplett anderes.
Ich weiß Dinge, ich sage es euch, aber ich... Also Tersic wird es nicht, kann ich sagen.
Welche Dinge weißt du? Du darfst es nicht so antifizieren, du darfst es nicht sagen.
Nee, also Tersic ist nicht... Den haben sie diskutiert bei Tottenham, aber da gab es also kein klares Antivotum. Aber schon Dinge, die sich haben gegen ihn positionieren lassen. Wenn es einen eigenmaßen Sinn ergibt. Also bei De Zerbi waren deutlich mehr Pro-Stimmen da und bei Tersic war er in allen Trainergängen, also sowohl vor Frank als auch nach Frank als auch nach Tudor, jeweils ein Thema, aber jeweils gab es Informationen, die sie haben Abstand nehmen lassen davon.
Also Tottenheim wird sich dann im Sommer von De Zerbi trainen, nachdem sie ihm vor einem Monat einen 5-Jahres-Vertrag gegeben haben.
Das wäre die logische Konsequenz. Aber angeblich, er sagte ja oder sagte vor seinem 1. Spiel, er würde mitgehen in die 2. Liga. Und wir haben ja beim letzten Mal schon gelernt, dass es realistischer ist, als wir uns alle jemals hätten ausmalen können. Und das ist, also 2. Spiel, muss ich jetzt auch dazu sagen, ich will jetzt gerne Tottenham-Thema aufmachen, aber 2. Spiel, da konnte man schon was erkennen im 1. Aber im 2. Spiel habe ich jetzt was erkannt. Das war ein Schritt in die richtige Richtung. Das Problem ist, nur alle anderen haben auch wieder gepunktet. Das ist das Dumme für Tottenham.
Haben sie nicht in der Nachspielzeit sogar das Gegentor kassiert, Uli?
Tottenham, ja. Ja, genau. Ja, genau. Aber trotzdem ist es ja so weit okay gewesen. Und die anderen, also Nottingham gewinnt wieder. Leeds ist jetzt durch. Also die haben gestern ja auch unentschieden gespielt. Die sind durch. Und jetzt geht es nur noch. West Ham hat einfach wenigstens gepunktet. Und Nottingham, ja, das sind sie ja, die drei. Das wird noch ausmachen unter sich, ja.
Ja, du. Also ganz im Ernst, wer jemanden wie Mason Greenwald so verteidigt, der darf auch wegen mir gerne mindestens ein Jahr in der 2. Liga coach sein. Aber das ist nochmal ein ganz anderes Thema. Aber darf jetzt auch nicht so komplett unerwähnt bleiben, wenn wir über die Serbis sprechen. Wir schauen noch einmal nochmal nach Italien und dann kommen wir nochmal kurz zur Premier League. Christian, was hast du uns denn aus der Serie A noch mitgebracht? Moment, wir schauen noch zweimal nach Italien, sehe ich gerade. Hi, hi, hi.
Ja, machen wir ein bisschen kurz auf den Punkt gebracht. Ja, bei der Roma ist einiges am brodeln, und zwar jetzt weniger auf dem Spielfeld, sondern abseits. Und zwar die Herren Ranieri und Gasperini, haben sich da jetzt öffentlich in ordentlichen Disput verwickelt. Kurz Hintergrund, also Ranieri ist ja seit dieser Saison sozusagen berater, offizieller berater des Klubs, der Eigentümer, hat ja letztes Jahr noch die Roma übernommen, auch in die Europa League geführt, hat einen Platz frei gemacht. Ist jetzt auch so ein bisschen von Massara, vom Sportdirektor sozusagen, da ist so ein bisschen die Position drüber. Und Gasperini wurde ja eben geholt im Sommer, um da jetzt alles, das neue Projekt auf den Weg zu bringen. Und ja, kurz sportlich, die Roma ist im Moment punktgleich mit Kormor fünfter, eben der Rückstand auf Juve, sind jetzt fünf Punkte im Rennen mit Champions League, wird es halt schon sehr eng. Aber eben wie gesagt, was so plötzlich jetzt wirklich fast aus dem Nichts kam, ist, dass vor zehn Tagen oder so Ranieri in einem Interview vor dem Spiel, der ziemlich losgelädert hat, erst mal solche Sachen gesagt hat, wie ja, Ranieri war ja ungefähr die dritte oder die vierte Wahl, ich habe mit mehreren gesprochen und dann haben sich die Eigentümer halt für Gasperini entschieden und habe ich das durchgezogen, hat ihn sehr stark kritisiert sozusagen auch, hat gemeint, ja, alle Transfers, die wir auch in dieser Saison getätigt haben, da war überall der Trainer involviert, denn Gasperini, vielleicht erinnern sich ein paar von euch, ist schon einer, der auch immer wieder mal ganz gerne öffentlich so ein paar Spitzen setzt. Er hat jetzt im Winter zum Beispiel davon gesprochen, ja, ihr müsst mir bei der Roma schon sagen, was ihr möchtet, soll ich hier junge Spieler aufbauen oder wollt ihr, dass ich in die Champions League komme? Also, Gasperini ist da oft sehr ehrlich, sagt da manchmal auch ein paar Sachen, die sicherlich nicht immer clever sind. Und das Außergewöhnliche war jetzt einfach, ich glaube, wir kennen alle Claudia Ranieri, der seit Jahrzehnten im Spiel ist, der diesen Elder-States-Man-Rolle ja auch wirklich über lange Zeit pflegt. Und ich mir ganz sicher bin, dass er logischerweise wusste, wenn er solche Sachen öffentlich sagt, was da dann los ist, gerade auf einem heißen Pflaster wie Rom. Und da tun sich jetzt halt alle schwer, das ein bisschen einzuordnen, denn er hat damit jetzt unbedingt dem Verein nicht einen Gefallen getan. Und der Verein ist ja den, den er über alles liebt, weil Ranieri, die Geschichte haben wir hier oft erzählt, über mehrere Male die Roma übernommen hat, ist auf seinem Ruhestand für die Roma zurückgekommen, ist diesen Club durch und durch liebt. Und die Vermutung, wir saßen alle nicht dabei bei den Gesprächen zwischen Ranieri und Gasperini, ist halt, dass er sich da von Gasperinis Art ein bisschen provozieren hat lassen und jetzt so eine Diskussion ins Rollen gebracht hat, die halt leider auch dem Club schadet. Und das bin ich mir sicher, das will ich Ranieri 0,0 unterstellen, das wollte der ganz sicher nicht, aber Club ist das, was er mit am meisten liebt. Und ja, also es ist wirklich eine bisschen surreale Situation, ganz kurz noch dazu, vor dem letzten Spiel, die Romad gegen Atalanta gespielt. Gasperini hat lange nichts dazu gesagt, zu diesen Vorwürfen sozusagen. Und auf der Spieltagspressekonferenz, jetzt vor dem letzten Spiel gegen Atalanta, hat er am Ende geweint und ist aufgestanden, gegangen, weil sie ihn sozusagen übermannt hat. Hat er auch an seine Andri Perkassis, also die Eigentümer von Atalanta erinnert, hat gemeint, wir haben da jahrelang was aufgebaut. Alle haben an einem Strang gezogen und dann hat er angefangen zu weinen und ist aufgegangen und hat die Tür hinter sich zugeknallt. Hat sich da wirklich auch, du hast gemerkt, der war menschlich angefasst, hat auch so aufgezählt. Ich war jetzt acht Jahre bei Atalanta, davor neun Jahre bei Genua. Vielleicht bin ich gar kein so schlechter Mensch. Also auch, du hast gemerkt, diese menschliche Ebene auch. Deswegen ist das eine Situation, die ziemlich überraschend kam und die die ROME aber sehr beschäftigt. Denn im Moment ist schwer vorstellbar, dass nach der Saison da beide noch da sein werden. Also Gasperini als Trainer und Ranieri in dieser leitenden Übersichtsfunktion. Ja, sehr, sehr hitzige Situation im Moment.
Ach, verrückt, was die Nebengeschichten manchmal im Fußball auch ausmachen. Wie viele Minuten haben wir schon nicht mehr über Sportliches geredet, aber es ist ja wirklich ein wichtiges Thema.
Ein kleiner Satz noch, dass nicht alles an Ranieri hängen bleibt. Ich kann es ja auch von außen noch mal. Was da intern zwischen denen vorgefallen ist, können wir nicht bewerten. Wie gesagt, Gasperini hat schon immer wieder dieses, weil die haben im Winter zum Beispiel einen Robinho Vaz von Marseille, ein 19-Jähriger, für viel Geld, ich glaube für 20 Millionen Euro. Dann hat da auch Venturino einen von Gennot bekommen, für einen 18-Jährigen. Auf der anderen Seite hat er auch Malen bekommen, der jetzt, wie wir alle wissen, sehr gut funktioniert. Und dieses immer wieder von Gasperini halt so ein bisschen, was möchtet ihr denn von mir, soll ich was entwickeln oder möchtet ihr Gleicherfolg? Das muss halt Ranieri anscheinend getriggert haben, weil Ranieri ja auch für diese strategischen Entscheidungen logisch auch steht. Und deswegen ist er da, so er sich raus. Aber was da genau wirklich dazu geführt, das ist wirklich schwer zu bewerten, weil nochmal, wenn einer weiß, wie dieses mediale Game funktioniert, dann ist es Claudio Ranieri. Und dementsprechend, ja, bin mal gespannt, was da auch nach, dass es so noch passiert. Wie gesagt, im Moment schwer vorstellbar, das dabei. Auch, obwohl die Fridkens die US-Eigentümer, um auch wieder mal Investoren ins Spiel zu bringen, waren jetzt für Minuten lang nicht das Thema. Die hoffen anscheinend, dass sie beide ja noch mal an einen Tisch bekommen. Aber ob das klappt, glaube ich, kann man im Moment mal ein Fragezeichen dahinter setzen.
Das ist eigentlich mit einer der witzigsten Aspekte der Investoren im Fußball, die wir jetzt haben, weil die oft mit so McKinsey-Management-Strategien rangehen. Da muss man nun Assessment-Center machen und dann wird das schon alles funktionieren. Und dann treffen sie auf die Branche. Noch einen Call mehr einstellen. Ja, genau. Wir machen jetzt einfach immer so einen Road-Up-Call am Anfang der Woche. Da treffen wir uns dann alle und da besprechen wir mal kurz, wie die KPI-Zielerfolgung so aussieht. Und dann treffen sie auf die Branche Fußball.
Und dann zerplatzt so manches Seifenblas.
Wenn der blöde Fußball nicht immer wäre, dann wäre alles viel besser.
Ja, und also das kann ich jetzt auch mit Sicherheit sagen, dass in dem Moment, in dem Investoren in den Fußball besonders reingekommen sind in den letzten Jahren, wirklich das Erstaunen groß darüber war, dass diese Milliardenbranche so arbeitet, wie sie arbeitet. Und das hatte ich vorher schon gehört von Leuten, die ich kannte, die zu Fußballvereinen in Deutschland gewechselt sind, dass sie gesagt haben, du würdest es nicht glauben, wie wir hier arbeiten. Und das haben Investoren auch festgestellt. Und haben dann aber festgestellt, ach so, es reicht gar nicht, dass wir eine Datenbank hinstellen, dann wird alles besser. Ach so, naja, dann bezahlen wir jetzt jemanden sehr, sehr viel.
Aber Moneyball.
Ja, ja, ja, aber Moneyball.
Alles ist doch Moneyball.
Es ist alles Moneyball.
Um wirklich allerletzter Satz dazu, um den menschlichen Faktor noch reinzubringen, es war ja auch sehr gespannt, wie die Fanszene reagiert. Weil die hängen ja extrem an Ranieri. Aber viele gehen auch mit Gasperin, also erstens wollen die logisch nicht in Disput, aber viele haben ja auch verstanden, dass Gasperin jetzt mal möglich der Trainer ist, mit dem man jetzt halt das Neue starten kann. Und deswegen war jetzt dieses Heimspiegel in Atalanta, waren sehr gespannt, wie sie reagieren. Und ich finde, die Curva Sud hat da sehr besonnen und gut reagiert. Da gab es ein riesiges Spruchband im schönen römischen Reim und so. Ich bringe es jetzt einfach inhaltlich zusammen, wo sie gemeint haben, hey, so ungefähr die Roma steht über Alben, so bitte kriegt euch wieder ein im Sinne der Roma. Und das fand ich schon sehr schön, weil eben wie gesagt, das wirklich auch, glaube ich, aus Fansicht ganz schwierig ist, weil jeder Roma-Fan liebt Claudia Ranieri, da gibt es keinen einzigen. Und aber die Roma-Fans sind schon auch diesen Gasperiniweg jetzt mitgegangen seit letztem Sommer. Und deswegen fand ich das schön, dass sie sich jetzt nicht auf der einen oder einen oder anderen Seite positioniert haben, sondern auch da nochmal appelliert haben, komm, die Roma steht über Alben ungefähr, hockt euch zusammen, diskutiert das aus. Ja, mal schauen, ob das auch gelingt.
Wir werden es verfolgen. Und was wir auch verfolgen werden, ist der nächste ehemalige Bundesligatrainer in der Premier League. Bournemouth wird Marco Rose verpflichten. Die erste Frage, die sich da stellt, beim Blick auf die Tabelle, Platz 7 mit 49 Punkten. Man ist unter anderem vor Chelsea. Also Bournemouth ist eins der Probleme, das Chelsea gerade hat. Man hat seit– ich weiß gar nicht, wie vielen Spielen– nicht mehr verloren. Allerdings sind auch viele Uneschi mit dabei. Also warum gibt es denn da überhaupt eine Veränderung auf der Trainerbank? Und wie kam man dann auf Marco Rose?
Weil Iraolas Vertrag zum Saisonende ausläuft und er ihn nicht verlängern will. Und das hat er, ich glaube, am 15. April bekannt gegeben, wenngleich das auch schon jetzt nicht so ein großes Geheimnis war, dass das drohen könnte. Also es hat sowieso jetzt jahrelang schon gedroht, weil Iraola natürlich viel, viel Interesse auf sich gezogen hat, sodass man davon ausgehen hätte können, dass sie vielleicht rausgelöst wird aus dem Vertrag. Jetzt hat das aber selbst entschieden, dass das natürlich zum Ende kommt. Und deshalb musste Bournemouth jetzt reagieren. Und deshalb hat es aber auch nicht lange gedauert, bis sie dann einen potenziellen Nachfolger parat hätten für ihn. Und das ist jetzt Marko Rose.
Und passt das da in der Meinung nach? Also ehrlicherweise, ich habe jetzt nicht so den Spieß, wie von Bournemouth vor Augen.
Ja, passt gar nicht schlecht. Also es ist im Wesentlichen bei Bournemouth, und das ist dann so, das ist dann Iraola-Thema irgendwann mal. Der wird irgendwo bei einem größeren Team auftauchen. Da bin ich mir sehr, sehr sicher.
Auch Bill Bauer übrigens, wenn ich dazwischen gräbschen darf.
Das liest man sehr oft, dass er das wohl…
Weil werde, hört auf im Sommer.
Genau, das liest man sehr oft, dass er das gerne wohl auch übernehmen würde, aus persönlichen Gründen, logischerweise. Also der kommt ja aus demselben Jugendteam da, wie alle. Wie jeder einzelne Trainer auf dieser Welt, der Erfolg hatte in den letzten drei Jahren. Es ist im Wesentlichen Aggression, Disziplin, aber ausschließlich gegen den Ball gerichtet, relativ basic am Ball. Das würde ich gerne sehen von ihm. Fairerweise muss man auch sagen, dem ist jedes Mal jeder Leistungsträger unter dem Hintern davon verkauft worden, sodass das eher für ihn spricht, dass es nie eingebrochen ist. Im Gegenteil, sie sich sogar immer noch Saison für Saison verbessern. Aber ich würde es trotzdem gerne sehen. Man steckt im Übrigen nicht in Booten, aber er fährt im selben Boot wie Oliver Glasner, dem ungefähr der gleiche Ruf voraus eilt in der Premier League. Die werden sich auch ungefähr um die gleichen Jobs streiten, minus jetzt ausgeklammert mal Bebauung, wenn das passieren sollte. Dann kann es schon sein, dass das da nicht passiert. Aber ansonsten sind die beiden relativ im selben Fahrwasser unterwegs. Aber gegen den Ball, super. Du kannst immer erkennen, von Spiel zu Spiel, von Monat zu Monat in der Premier League, wie viel besser alles funktioniert bei ihm. Und wie er sie einfach drillt dazu, saubere, lange Bälle zu spielen, aber auch taktische Fouls. Siehst du, wahnsinnig clever, dass sie viel weniger in der eigenen Hälfte faulen als in der gegnerischen Hälfte, um direkt schon Dinge einfach gar nicht passieren zu lassen. Viele Fouls, wenig hart und dann eben sehr, sehr viel auch im Kaderbau. Also da wird ziemlich clever gearbeitet, sehr, sehr viel im Kaderbau so eingekauft, damit man auch so ein Umschaltsystem nutzen kann. Und wenn ich das jetzt so sage, dann glaube ich, ist das fast ein Charakterzug, den Marco Rose so auch hat. Ich habe immer gefunden, am Ball, na ja, aber gegen den Ball, wenn er sich darauf beschränkt hat, ja, dann passt das ganz gut. Von daher, ja, das einzige Problem, was ich habe dabei ist, dass Rose ja auch öffentlich ziemlich unglücklich war über das Arbeiten mit ausschließlich Talenten und relativ wenig Perspektive mit erfahrenen Spielern oder mal irgendwas zu erreichen. Und das wird jetzt hier nochmal zum Exzess getrieben, weil da ist ein Geschäftsmodell bei Bournemouth dahinter. In dem Fall ist es Bill Foley, der da sein Ding da hat, Black Knight Konsortium. Da gibt es ja auch wieder ein paar, was haben wir, Lurian ist glaubt drin, Hibernian, also die Hips, die Original. Dann Oakland und Morai Rense oder Moen, wie man in Portugal wahrscheinlich sagen würde. Einfach so und das ist auch nur ein Geschäftsmodell da, das hat auch für sie jetzt funktioniert. Auf den ersten Blick passt es. Auf den zweiten Blick bin ich total auch gespannt, wie Rose auch klarkommt an der Südküste, weil das ist noch mal ein eigenes Völkchen da in England. Sein Englisch ist solala, wenn ich das richtig weiß. Und er ist dann schon auch jemand, der irgendwann mal fordernd wird. Also ich bin sehr gespannt. Aber rein spielerisch auf den ersten Blick habe ich gedacht, nachdem ich zwei Umdrehungen gebraucht habe, ja, ja, eigentlich ja.
Ja, interessant, dass immer noch so viele in der Bundesliga auch tätige Trainer in der Premier League landen, also nach Hürzela und Fahke, wobei der eigentlich fast eher ein Premier League Trainer ist, als ein Bundesligatrainer und ehrlich ist, und Uli Glasner jetzt dann der Vierte in dieser Reihe. Sind wir mal gespannt, wie es läuft bei Bournemouth. Und dann wollen wir nochmal nach Italien blicken, Christian. Denn auch da gab es im Pokalfinale schöne Geschichten, die man erzählen kann.
Genau, im Pokalhalbfinale, richtig. Genau, Aktualität, Dienstag und Mittwoch wurde gespielt, ganz kurz. Das Finale lautet jetzt Inter gegen Lazio. Inter hat sich gegen Como durchgesetzt, war sehr spektakulär. Das Rückspiel Como hat 2-0 geführt in der zweiten Halbzeit der Insan Siro nach dem 0-0 im Hinspiel. Ja, und dann hat Inter das noch mit drei Toren gedreht. Celanolo, Doppelpack, starke Vorstellung. Also Inter jetzt mit der Riesenchance aufs Dubel. Und im anderen Halbfinale war Atalanta gegen Lazio, also für beide die große Chance, Titel, ja, Titel Sehnsucht zu befriedigen. Das war sehr spektakulär. Hinspiel schon 2-2, Rückspiel 2-2. Es ging ins Elfmeterschießen und jetzt kommen wir kurz auf den Herren, der ja da jetzt im Impelpunkt steht. Das Elfmeterschießen hat angefangen mit 2 Lazio-Fehlschüssen, die ersten zwei. Und Lazio hat das Elfmeterschießen trotzdem gewonnen, innerhalb der 5 Schützen, weil ein gewisser Eduardo Motta, 21 Jahre jung, Torhüter von Lazio, einfach mal 4 Elfmeter in Folge pariert hat. Und dieser Herr Motta ist eine schöne Geschichte. Da kann ich jetzt sogar die Brücke zum Premier League-Thema auch schön schließen. Denn die Lazio-Torhüter im Winter waren Providel und Mandas. Providel war lange schon bei Lazio die 1, Mandas, junger Grieche, war die letzten Jahre sehr aufstremt. Den hat Lazio im Winter für 20 Millionen Euro an Bournemous verkauft, um jetzt hier schön den Kreis zu schließen. Was Herrn Sarri, den Trainer von Lazio, alles andere als amüsiert hat. Der hat damals gesagt, das können wir nicht machen, wir haben dann nur noch Providel, wenn dem was passiert, was machen wir dann? Hat der Verein trotzdem gemacht, langes Thema, Lazio tun Verkäufe auch sehr gut. Der Fakt war, dass kurze Zeit später sich wirklich Providel schwer verletzt hat, monatelang ausgefallen ist. Und Lazio hat im Winter diesen Eduardo Mota aus der 2. Liga von Reggiana, vom letztplatzierten der 2. Liga, für eine Million Euro geholt. Providel verletzt sich schwer. Jetzt spielt dieser Mota seit Anfang März. Und er spielt richtig gut. Es geht eben nicht nur um diese vier gehaltenen Elfmeter. Das ist jetzt logisch die Geschichte der Saison. Aber Mota war auch in der Liga unter ihm. Hat Lazio nur noch einmal verloren seit Anfang März. Die haben Milan geschlagen, die haben Napoli geschlagen, die haben Bologna geschlagen. Mota hat auch da in der Liga in Bologna Elfmeter gegen Orsullini gehalten, sprich, seine aktuelle Elfmeter-Statistik sind 6 Elfmeter, 5 davon gehalten in den letzten zwei Monaten. Und eben wie gesagt, jetzt bitte nicht nur auf die Elfmeter reduzieren, sondern der hat einen richtig guten Eindruck gemacht. 21 Jahre jung, vom Tabellenletzten der 2. Liga für eine Million Euro geholt. Das ist die Geschichte im Moment bei Lazio. Stammt aus der Jugend von Juve, war dann viel, wie man es von italienischen jungen Spielern kennt, wurde immer wieder ausgeliehen, mal da an Laia, mal da an Laia, mal da an Laia. Und jetzt unter der Skepsis des eigenen Clubs fährt er jetzt so auf, bringt Lazio ins Pokalfinale. Wie wir alle wissen, das Pokalfinale findet in Italien im Rom statt. Auch da gibt es dieses wunderschöne 50-50 bei den Kurven mit 25.000 Mann. Lazio hat jetzt sozusagen ein kleines Heimspiel im Finale. Der letzte Punkt dazu, die Frage ist, füllen sie es auch, denn Lazio, die Lazio-Fans haben die letzten Wochen teilweise die Heimspiele boikottiert, weil das Verhältnis zu Club Boslo Tito sehr angespannt ist. Es gab zuletzt Lazio-Heimspiele mit 4.000 oder 5.000 Zuschauern. Und Maurizio Sarri, der jetzt wirklich auch den ersten Titel mit Lazio gewinnen kann, hat nur gemeint, jetzt nach dem Elfmeterschießen mein größter Traum ist, dass hoffentlich alle Lazio-Fans eben zum Finale kommen und das Stadion voll machen. Ich glaube, das wird auch passieren, weil es logisch in der Heimat statt im Pokalfinale zu haben, was ganz besonders ist. Und dieser Herr Eduardo Motta schreibt im Prinzip ja so ein bisschen im Moment das kleine italienische Fußballmärchen. Und ist ein Beweis dafür, dass es in der 2. Liga in Italien auch einige gute, talentierte, junge Italiener gibt, denen man vielleicht auch hin und wieder auch eine Chance geben könnte in der 1. Liga.
Nicht schon mal Musiala in die Serie B stecken.
Zum Beispiel. Ja, zwar wollen wir Motta nicht zu Musiala machen, aber ob er so viel Talent mitbringt, würde ich mal ein Fragezeichen dahinter setzen. Nee, aber es ist logisch eine besondere Geschichte. Also, dass da man ja noch beim Tabellenletzten der 2. Liga. Und wie gesagt, nicht nur die Elfmeter, weil ich glaube, das wissen wir alle. Klar kann Torhüter auch mal ein paar Elfmeter halten, aber der hat wirklich Ruhe ausgestrahlt auch in der Liga. Wie gesagt, Milan geschlagen, Napoli geschlagen, Bologna geschlagen, nur einmal verloren. Jetzt noch dieses Stück oben drauf. Ja, ich glaube, Sarri ist mittlerweile auch von Motta überzeugt.
Nicht verwandt und verschwägert, übrigens mit anderen bekannten Mottas.
Mottas, nee, definitiv nicht.
Diese Mottin wäre jetzt die richtige Mehrzahl gewesen.
Es müsste ja A-Konjugation sein, dann wäre es ja Motte. Aber das ist ja komplett anders. Ich dachte nur, weil wir schon so häufig über quasi Zöglinge von ehemaligen Profis gesprochen haben, dass ich es dann lieber hier nochmal mit dazu sage.
Aber habt ihr als Erinnerung, habt ihr schon mal ein Elfmeterschießen in Erinnerung, wo vier in Folge und zwar auch alle gehalten, also nicht verschossen, der hat die alle gehalten. Schon sehr außergewöhnlich, oder? Also mir ist nichts eingefallen.
Es gab mal eins bei der Frauen-WM 2015 im Viertelfinale, glaube ich, ne Viertelfinale war das dann. Aber da wurden auch so wahnsinnig viele nacheinander verschossen. Aber es ist irre. Vor allem, ich habe es nicht mitbekommen, ich habe es jetzt nur durch dich mitbekommen, deswegen vielen Dank. Aber das muss ich ja auch unglaublich anfühlen. Du trist den Ersten als Atalanta, dann verschießt Lazio für zwei in Serie. Aber das heißt, du führst quasi bis zum dritten Elfmeterschützen, führst du immer noch mit zwei zu eins. Und dann geht es auf die Linie.
Und gehst nach fünf Elfmetern als Verlierer raus. Die Geschichte musst du aus Atalantas Sicht auch erst mal schreiben. Definitiv.
Aber wirklich. Naja, ihr drei, das hat große Freude gemacht. Ich werde zwei Sendungen verlinken, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Die könntet ihr sehr gut jetzt nochmal anhören, wenn ihr sie noch nicht gehört habt. Zum einen eben, wie Investoren den Fußball umbauen. Ich glaube wirklich, dass da ein bisschen was drinsteckt, was ihr wahrscheinlich auch so noch nicht anderswo gehört habt, weil meinem Eindruck nach hat es eben einfach in Deutschland niemand so wirklich berichtet, was da bei CWC gerade so los ist. Und das ist ja nur der Startpunkt unserer Diskussion. Und die zweite Sendung ist eben die zum WM aus Italiens. Da haben wir eben über viele Themen gesprochen, die wir jetzt am Schluss jetzt auch nochmal so indirekt angesprochen haben. Junge italienischer Torhüter, der jetzt dann doch eine Chance bekommt in der Serie A. Freuen wir uns doch. Also ihr drei. Ich danke euch sehr, sehr herzlich. Herzlichen Dank an Uli Hebel. Danke dir.
Danke dir.
Vielen Dank an Alex Truica. War wie immer eine Freude, junger Mann.
Sehr gerne, junger Mann.
Und herzlichen Dank an Christian Bernhard.
Die Alten sind immer zu spät hier.
Ja, ich sag Danke, Max.
Und ich danke natürlich auch euch, lieben Hörerinnen und Hörer. Denn ihr wisst ja, alles im Rasenfunk ist paywall, werbe- Und ganz im Ernst, so wie sich Werbung im Podcast grad verändert, können wir alle nur drei Kreuze machen, dass dem so ist. Sowohl ihr als KonsumentInnen und ich als derjenige, der es produziert. Und ich muss es dann nur in anderen Podcasts hören. Also vielen, vielen Dank, dass ihr das möglich macht. Wie ihr uns Geld zukommen lassen könnt, das erfahrt ihr in der Podcast- und der Videobeschreibung. Oder in dem ihr auf rasenfunk.de geht und dort auf den Unterstützen-Button klickt. In dieser Folge möchte ich mich bedanken bei Ben Viva Soccer Gumos, schreibt er bei Tartan, Ami, bei Dirk, bei Neuer Nick und bei Sostenitori. Ganz herzlichen Dank für euren Support. Und wenn ihr Feedback habt zu dieser Sendung oder auch zu anderen, die ihr gehört habt, dann sehr gerne unter mitmachen.rasenfunk.de. Freuen wir uns sehr drüber. Und wir würden uns natürlich auch freuen, wenn ihr diese Sendung hier weiterempfehlt. Denn da steckt ja doch so einiges drin, was vielleicht auch noch andere Fußballfans interessieren könnte. In diesem Sinne, danke für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Bis bald hier wieder im Rasenfunk. Bleibt uns gewogen und vor allem aber bleibt oder werdet gesund. Bis bald, macht's gut, ciao.
Der Rasenfunk lebt von euren Beiträgen. Vielen Dank.